We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two David P..
This voicemail is a good voicemail.
Aside from being disgusting to talk about
what we can control and what we cannot control.
Take a listen to this.
Put this on your freaking stupid sideshow.
You know, you're nothing but a greasy Venezuelan.
Why don't you go back?
You're in Greece, that place.
And you sit here and you throw your hands
around.
You know, you look like a wounded freaking
chicken.
You're an asshole.
And Biden is going to lose and lose big.
So screw you, you ass.
There you go.
So, of course, on the facts, I've never been
to Venezuela Margined Tinian.
I am not a fan of the Hugo Chavez.
Nicolas Maduro regime.
I have no real interest in going to Venezuela.
Period.
So that's number one.
That's just sort of that xenophobia.
Listen, South America, it's all kind of the
same, doesn't really matter, etc..
OK.
This is an opportunity to talk about what
we can and we cannot control because the caller
does say Biden's going to lose and he's going
to lose big.
And I think that in this moment in time, it
is a very sort of good opportunity to understand
the teachings of the Stoics.
I'm talking about Marcus Aurelius.
I'm talking about Seneca.
I'm talking about.
I don't know if it's pronounced Epictetus
or Epictetus where we need to understand that
there are really three categories of things
in the world.
They are the things over we at which we have
total control.
Like, for example, I can have total control
about my over my goals.
I decide what are my goals.
I have complete control.
There are things over which I have no control
like.
Is the sun going to rise tomorrow?
I have no control over that.
There's no point in worrying about that and
thinking about that.
And then there's the area over which we have
some control.
The election is one of those cases.
I can control the message I put out on this
program.
I can control how I vote.
I can control whether I make the best effort
possible to convince people that they should
vote and they should vote for Joe Biden.
But that's as far as my control goes.
And, you know, all of this stuff about people
expect.
Me to cry on election night, if Biden doesn't
win, I'm going to be very sad because of what
it means for our country.
But I'm going to know I did everything I could.
And then we'll just have to proceed forward.
Right.
Life will go on.
It will be a worse life, certainly for the
average person.
If Joe Biden doesn't win.
But, you know, all these people with these
personal vendettas, they want to see me cry
on election night.
This is not about me.
But I do think it's a good opportunity for
us to understand where does our our sphere
of influence end.
And as long as we feel that we did everything
we could, that's as far as we really have
control.
Something to keep in mind in advance of whatever
the results are on November 3rd or whatever
day we find out the results.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about Labor Day as a possible
coronavirus spike event.
We will talk about young Americans living
at home with their parents in greater numbers
than we've seen for a long time since the
Great Depression.
In fact, and much more get access to today's
Bonas show and every bonus show by becoming
a member at join Pacman dot com.